[Musique]
désert de mojave en californie une
surface aride grande comme la hollande
une terre hostile où il fait 40 degrés
mais pour cet homme michael aris
c'est un terrain idéal pour partir à la
chasse au trésor un trésor exceptionnel
on chasse principalement des jeans du
19e siècle fabriqué à san francisco on
va dans des mines abandonnées des
décharges de cette période 1870 1880
ils ont été jetés à l'époque et nous on
les cherche
michael est peintre en bâtiment dans la
vraie vie
chasser les vieux jeans est sa passion
son objectif aujourd'hui une mine
d'argent désaffecté en plein désert
michael retrouve son beau-père et
compagnon de chasse russes miller 71 ans
salut grâce à lui mike ça va
après deux heures de marche les
chasseurs de jean arrive enfin à
destination pour deux jours de fouilles
michael et reuze des blagues des tonnes
de callas dans un danger permanent
les pierres peuvent s'écrouler à tout
moment je dois appeler ma femme toutes
les deux heures pour lui dire que je
vais bien
personne ne s'inquiète pour moi
on a eu une alerte
oui les premiers petits éboulements il
décide de s'arrêter pour la nuit et le
lendemain matin
enfin ils font une découverte regarde où
ça tout en bas et c'est ce qu'on
cherchait ça on a trouvé quelque chose
c'est un lévis ne le déchirent pas je me
demande si on ne peut pas le sortir en
passant par en dessous
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chose de jeans levi's il ya
quelque chose dedans
non non non il n'y a absolument rien
c'est sûr qu'il ya une paire de jeans
quelque part ici c'est super ça date de
1893 1894 quelque chose comme ça c'est
sûr tout ici remonte à cette époque
c'est génial
c'est une journée formidable quand on
trouve quelque chose comme ça ça me fait
tellement plaisir ça valait le coup
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est très rare de trouver quelque chose
la poche ne vaut que 130 euros mais cela
veut dire qu'il y a encore des fortunes
à se faire dans la mine aux etats unis
le jean vintage le vieux jean connaît
une mode sans précédent les premiers
pantalon en toile de de nîmes date de la
fin du 19e siècle avec les premiers
lévis et leur succès ne s'est jamais
démentie plus les jeans sont vieux plus
ils sont prisés et certains se sont
spécialisés dans leurs recherches
on les appelle les jeans heures toujours
à l'affût de la pièce rare qu'une
poignée de fous furieux est prêt à payer
des dizaines de milliers d'euros plus
les jeans sont vieux puits ils valent de
l'or
le record en ce moment ce sont des jeans
des années 1870 qui se sont vendus entre
45 milles et 55 mille euros c'est la
ruée vers l'or bleu
nous retrouvons michael le chasseur de
jean chez lui à los angeles
il nous montre le bilan de 10 ans de
fouilles dans les mines 4 chemise et
quatre pantalons seulement mais sa
collection atteint des centaines de
milliers d'euros voici un green bay
brothers de 1874 il vaut 9000 euros
malgré son mauvais état un rarissime
lévis grizzlies toujours de 1874 6000
euros
l'un de mes plus beaux coups c'est un
lévis avec poche à outils que j'ai mis
en vente sur ebay en 2008
un collectionneur japonais l'a payé
27000 euros
mais michael a encore mieux voici le
plus beau de ses trésors qu'il ne peut
se résoudre à vendre
même s'il vit chichement sur son salaire
de peintre en bâtiment et voici la plus
belle pièce de ma collection de jeans
date de 1873 il y à des détails qui
permettent de le prouver il devrait se
vendre entre 90 milles et 140000 euros
voilà pourquoi michael retourne encore
et toujours dans ses mines abandonnées
il veut croire qu'il y à d'autres
trésors là bas
5h30 du matin le jour se lève à peine
sur le marché aux puces de l'ong beach à
los angeles
les brocanteurs commence tout juste à
installer leur stand
un homme est déjà à l'affût de la bonne
affaire salut jim james comole un
chercheur de vieux jeans lui aussi une
sorte de traders en or bleu bob tu veux
combien pour cette veste 200 200 c'est
ça c'est un peu cher pour une veste des
années 60
allez on continue né en thaïlande est
installé en californie depuis 20 ans il
achète et revend les jean vintage au
meilleur prix nous le retrouvons chez
lui dans son garage transformé en
showroom il reçoit l'un de ces pickers
comme on les appelle ici un dénicheur de
jean qui vient lui vendre ses
trouvailles
comment ça va tu as quelque chose pour
moi j'ai un truc super s'écoule à ils
sont beaux ces jeans est vraiment bien
j'ai un peu de tout combien tu me
proposes pour cela un bon prix un
honnête mans le mieux que je puisse le
proposer pour ses jeans et 310 euros
l'unité en bon trader il les revendre à
deux fois plus cher à un collectionneur
pas mal pour deux minutes de
négociations mais il ya encore d'autres
moyens de se faire de l'argent avec les
vieux jeans après le trader voici le
créateur boots aux pieds paire de jeans
blousons en cuir
et pick-up cheuvreux la vintage avec
plaque d'immatriculation à son nom mr
freedom monsieur liberté
[Musique]
il n'est pas américain c'est un frenchie
christophe loiron né à montpellier en
1966 résidant à los angeles depuis 25
ans il est tombé dans la marmite
culturelle américaine tout jeune homme
au point d'adopter la coupe et la voix
d'elvis sur des chansons de sa
composition
[Musique]
25 ans plus tard adieu guitare et
bananes reste les jeans
il en a fait son business il crée des
jeans 9 en s'inspirant des vieux modèles
alors là on est dans l'antre du lot son
magasin situé à hollywood évidemment est
une caverne d'ali baba pour amoureux de
la fringue vintage mais ici tout est
neuf sorties de l'atelier de couture de
christophe j'étais au départ un chineur
chineurs fou jallet j'ai fait toutes les
fripes l'ailé droite à gauche et j'ai
commencé à accumuler ça et il y avait
une demande de la part des stylistes qui
étaient intéressés par ces par toutes
ces vieilleries et une chose en sommes
dans l'autre je suis arrivé à créer mes
propres mes propres vêtements aussi
christophe s'est lancé dans le jean de
luxe il nous montre l'une de ses
dernières créations imitation années 50
ce pantalon par exemple qui était
inspiré d'un pantalon de la us navy des
années des années 40 avec un rapport
l'ex dernier pas de couture sur la jambe
et avec la martingale derrière très
typique des années 30 et 40
jean toujours fabriqués à partir de
coton appelé de nîmes
un mélange franco américain comme lui
alors voilà un rouleau de denim brut
pourquoi denim parce que c'était une
toile qui à l'origine viendrait de la
ville de nîmes en france teint avec un
bleu indigo
dont la petite histoire dit que c'est un
bloc qui venait de gênes blood eugène
jean les blue jeans un nom d'origine
française mais une histoire 100%
américaine écrite par les chercheurs
d'or il y a plus d'un siècle
mais aujourd'hui ceux qui poursuivent
l'histoire ceux qui font monter les prix
aux états unis ceux qui sont à l'origine
de cette folie jean se trouvent au japon
tokyo la mégapole de 35 millions
d'habitants
parmi eux y amar ammour à occupation
collectionneur de vieux jeans il les
aime tellement qu'ils les réparent lui
même j'ai appris à coudre tout seul
yamar année pas couturier il est
électricien ou plutôt il était sa
passion à manger sa vie au japon c'est
le collectionneur le plus connu du
milieu il y à une rumeur comme quoi j'ai
dépensé 150 mille euros en vieux jeans
en vérité j'ai plutôt dépenser entre 150
et 220 mille euros parce que j'adore les
gins y amara à 42 ans tout l'argent
qu'il a épargné dans sa vie est passée
dans ses jeans sa plus belle pièce
la voici il y a une étiquette manuscrite
ce jean a été fabriqué le 16 septembre
c'est un miracle de voir un produit
comme celui-là vieux de 80 ans est tout
neuf et parce qu'il est neuf qu'il n'a
jamais été portée il vaut beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent parce qu'on est payé
au prix du marché
trente sept mille euros
[Rires]
il n'en revient toujours pas mais c'est
comme ça il ne peut pas s'en empêcher il
a déjà 2000 jean est chez lui pas de
naphtaline collectionner ça veut dire
porter aussi celui-là a été fabriqué aux
états unis pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale sur le marché il vaut entre
3000 et 4000 euros
vous n'avez pas peur de les abîmer non
parce que je peux les réparer et en plus
comme ça le pantalon continue de vivre
et justement si la mara aime les vieux
jeans c'est parce que ça lui permet de
s'approprier leur histoire de faire
revivre les fantômes du passé
ce pantalon faisait partie des stocks
livrés à l'armée américaine pendant la
guerre pour les ouvriers qui
travaillaient à la fabrication des
avions militaires
l'homme devait être à genoux et là c'est
une tache d'huile de moteur vous voyez
il devait travailler comme ça il y avait
de l'huile par terre
je pense que c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé pour continuer à financer sa
passion
il s'est donc improvisé couturier il
répare maintenant les vieux jeans des
autres amateurs et sa collection
continue de grandir comme pour michael
l'homme qui fouillent les mines
abandonnées
la chasse ne s'arrêtera jamais